ح بين المذبحه والمذبحه او قل في الوقت
المستقطع من لحظه اطلاق الصاروخ حتى وصوله
الى اجسادهم يقتطعون لحظات تكفي للاحتفاء
بالحياه لا اهميه طبعا ولا اعتبار لمشهد
كهذا فيما يسمى اللعبه السياسيه التي
تتحرك الاله العسكريه على وقعها ووفق
خططها
في زمن احتفالهم خلف الدمار العظيم يجوب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
عواصم المنطقه بحثا عن جواب لسؤال اليوم
التالي لانتهاء الحرب وذاك سؤال يستند الى
فرضيه مفادها حتميه القضاء على الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وفي مقدمتها حركه حماس لكن
تجربه 30 يوما مضت حتى الان على اندلاع
الصراع بصوره الماساويه التي يشاهدها
العالم على الهواء مباشره تقول ان
المستهدفين علنا بقرار التصفيه ما زالوا
يقاتلون ويتصدون لعمليات التوغل البري
ويوقعون خسائر بشريه وماديه مؤكده في صفوف
تشكيلات عسكريه توغلت داخل مناطقهم بينما
لم تؤدي غارات الطيران الحربي وقصفه
المستمر على المدن والقرى والمخيمات الا
الى نتيجه عمليه مؤداها قتل ما يقرب من 10
الاف مدني واصابه نحو 300 غالبيتهم
الساحقه من الاطفال والنساء وسط مباركه
غربيه علنيه غير مسبوقه في تاريخ العالم
المعاصر واذ تشير المعلومات التي رشحت عن
الحراك الدبلوماسي الموازي للحرب الى
صعوبه العثور على طرف يقبل بالذهاب لاداره
قطاع غزه على ظهور الدبابات الاسرائيليه
فان سؤال ما العمل لانتشار للمنطقه من
الهاويه التي هي فيها الان سرعان ما لقي
جوابا بالغ الدلاله على لسان وزير التراث
الاسرائيلي عميحاي الياهو الذي قال ان
القاء قنبله نوويه على غزه امر وارد هذا
التصريح اثار من فوره ردود فعل واسعه في
اسرائيل لان الياهو رد على سؤال استدراكي
اخر عن مصير الاسرائيليين المحتجزين لدى
حماس في حال كهذه قائلا ان للحرب اثمان
وان هؤلاء ليسوا اهم من الجنود الذين
يضحون ويقتلون اما قتل مليونين و300
فلسطيني بالقنبله النوويه التي اقترحها
الوزير الاسرائيلي فلم يلتفت اليه
الغاضبون من تصريحاته داخل اسرائيل نفسها
الا لكونه سيسبب لها حرجا دبلوماسيا امام
العالم في وقت تكافح فيه ضد الاتهامات
الموجهه اليها بانتهاك القانون الد الدولي
الانساني كيف لا وثمه ما يشبه الاجماع
هناك على تاييد عمليات القصف الجوي
المستمره منذ شهر كامل والتي قدر خبراء
عسكريون حاصل جمعها بنحو قنبلتين نوويتين
لا مجرد واحده لذلك يعاقب الوزير صاحب
التصريح الفاشي بحرمانه من حضور جلسات
الحكومه ويتواصل القصف الذي يبيد
الفلسطينيين بالتجزئه بدلا من ابادتهم
دفعه واحده ولا احد بين صناع اللعبه
السياسيه التي تتحرك الاله العسكريه على
وقعها ووفق خططها يتذكر ان المغازي
وجباليا والبريج والنصيرات ليست قواع
عسكريه بل هي مخيمات لاجئين بائسه وان من
يقتلون في ازقتها الفقيره بالمئات كل يوم
هم ابناء واحفاد الفلسطينيين الذين طردوا
من اراضيهم وديارهم قبل 75 سنه لتقام دوله
اسرائيل
عليها لا غربه الحال هذه ان يكتشف هؤلاء
مبكرا هدف التخلص من وجودهم على ارض وطنهم
وان يصطفى عشرات منهم في مدرسه الفاخوره
التي تعرضت للقصف واعيد بناؤها اكثر من
مره لينشد عهدا امام الله بان لا يفعلوا
ما فعل اسلافهم عهدا بان لا يرحلوا من
ديارهم و لا يصدقوا وعدا باعادته حتى لو
كان موتهم هو ثمن
بقائهم